[Music]
grab a mortar and pestle to make a spicy
marinade for the chicken
crack open cardamom pods and add
ground ginger
coriander
cinnamon
grated nutmeg
cloves of garlic
fresh coriander
lemon juice
olive oil
and season
[Music]
now pulverize to form a paste
pour over the chicken thighs and leave
to marinade for up to two hours
[Applause]
to cook griddle on a high heat to get
wonderfully charred meat
once the chicken is cooked warm through
tortilla wraps on the same griddle
then simply slice your chicken
[Music]
and put your wrap together
top with shredded cabbage
[Applause]
chopped spring onion
and your favorite chili sauce
ready in 20 minutes sticky succulent and
utterly moorish spiced chicken wrap
[Music]
start by chopping chicken thighs into
pieces
now on with the marinade
chopped garlic
ginger
red chili
and lemon juice
in a pan toast coriander and cumin seeds
to release their flavors grind and add
to the chicken
then pour over plain yogurt
add turmeric and season
mix and leave to marinate from two hours
to overnight
next fry chopped onions in olive oil
then add chopped garlic and ginger
ground coriander garam masala
and turmeric
tomato puree and butter
next add the marinade chicken and all
the remaining marinade and cook until
tender
finally top with coriander
marinated for flavor and cooked in 20
minutes chili chicken with ginger and
coriander a simple stress-free wander
[Music]
start by making the intense jerk
marinade
first scotch bonnet chilis they may be
small but pack real heat and a fruity
punch
then chopped garlic
[Applause]
and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice add ground cloves
cinnamon
nutmeg
[Music]
and allspice
season with salt and pepper and combine
with olive oil
next score chicken legs so the hot spicy
flavors get deep inside the meat
rub thoroughly with the jerk mix and
marinade
[Applause]
and olive oil to a hot dish
[Music]
brown the marinaded chicken for 10
minutes then add worcestershire sauce
cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
[Music]
hot spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
finger licking good
[Music]
jack
hi am i gonna help with some pickling
please oh definitely now you love
pickles right love pickles um favorite
pickle what is it i like pickled onions
we're gonna do pickled celery mm-hmm
it's a nice little snack and great for
plum ones great for salads first thing i
want you to pick the celery for me so
you see where the next one's gonna be
it's in there yeah okay i'll figure it
out but i'm hungry today is this all
we're having for dinner jack come on i
wouldn't do that to you you know that
there's more coming now because we're
picking it
we want to sort of make it
look a little bit more attractive so we
go around like that
okay on an angle
so when you pick all the food does it
does it preserve it it's exactly what it
does but also gives it a really nice
salty
soury flavor yeah okay now splash of
water and then with the sugar nice okay
so we've got to bring that up to the
bowl
and sort of create
almost like a little syrup yeah okay
little teaspoon of peppercorns in
mustard seeds in quite generous on the
mustard seeds that gives a bit of sort
of spice now those you must know
cloves excellent cloves
in
now a touch of salt no
okay
so from there white wine vinegar now
in order for all that to actually
pickle
you need to boil it
so by boiling it
okay it brings all the ingredients
together it fuses all the spices
and
helps cook with celery have a little
taste
nice nice see i put some hairs on your
chest
yes it was good look boom it's working
already now see
nice
wine vinegar
right celery's ready yeah okay let's
walk to the ball now
turn that off
now
from there let's start placing the
celery
into that jar so when you pick other
foods can you use that same recipe
exactly that
100
once it's pickled it doesn't really go
off mm-hmm okay now put them in there so
can we eat this straight away when it's
in here do you know what as soon as it's
cooled down
you can definitely eat that straight
away i can't wait to dig into it at
dinner aren't they delicious yes we'll
leave that to cool down
our pickles are ready and cooling now to
marinate the chicken when you fried
chicken traditionally it's always gonna
be done with the dark meat the brown
meat so you got that nice sort of uh
drum
here and this bit
yeah that's thigh cooking on the bone as
well keeps it even more moist so first
things first salt pepper please
from there famous buttermilk buttermilk
in it's brilliant for marinating the
chicken if you can put this
buttermilk over your chicken
the night before the more it tenderizes
the chicken and starts to sort of really
relax
the chicken and puts a really nice sort
of
creamy soury flavor in there so might
stick that in the fridge for us please
ready the buttermilk should have worked
its magic on the chicken all that's left
is to fry it now we're going to
roll the chicken
out of the buttermilk into the flour so
that's why it gets nice and crispy and
blistery on the outside
okay cool so what we've got to make sure
because the flour is the last coat yeah
this is nicely seasoned yeah okay so
salt and pepper in there
nice
and this
is smoked paprika
so that gives it a little bit of sort of
uh
maybelline
yeah spice that's right a little bit of
heat and this one my favorites what's
that
cayenne pepper that's right again
slightly spicy but
the heat works brilliantly well
garlic powder traditionally are used a
lot in the steaks onion powder garlic
powder just run your fingers through
that please cool i'm gonna get the pan
on now
two centimetres
of oil this is a really good mix for
fish as well mm-hmm gujjon's fighting
a nice spicy
texture helps fish
so first thing
is we just shake off some of the
buttermilk lay that down yes okay really
important to get them covered completely
okay
in the flour yeah okay
so i love fried chicken do you
now
lift that up there the first one and you
place it in there away from you off you
go nice and gently
good and lay away good
if any stage you think the oil is
getting too hot yep just add a touch of
cold oil in there yeah or turn off the
gas
good
gently fry the chicken for 25 to 30
minutes or until cooked through
now very carefully turn them over please
yeah cool
can we have this every day
jack fried chicken every day no
definitely not it's a treat and it's
shallow fried so once every three weeks
yeah sounds great to me yeah
now
off with the gas
okay yeah paper ready okay onto the
paper
sell them
oh nice
um
i love
fried chicken i'm telling you i'm pretty
sure i love it morning look here's the
best bit
delicious now
fried chicken
pickles if you pick up um dulce de leche
cakes we are ready bud
very nice that's good
[Music]
one of the things i love about cooking
and that keeps me excited after 25 years
behind the stove is that there's always
something new to learn every day new
ingredients new techniques and new
cuisines
start off with the stuffing
it's amazing how exciting a stuffed
roast chicken can be because it keeps
the chicken incredibly moist and gives a
delicious texture inside the bird
i'm going to start off with cured cereso
this is a traditional spanish sausage
and it's
garlicky spicy incredibly meaty
that gives a little bit of sort of
richness to the stuffing
get that chorizo in
start cooking that down and getting all
those oils out
touch the olive oil in there to get it
going right onions
chopped
add the onions to the ceriso and in a
matter of seconds they'll change color
as they soak up all the flavor
that lovely spiciness has been stolen
from that sausage now the onions smell
incredible
garlic
garlicky
fresh thyme just hold it down and get
your fingers on there and it's a really
nice way of taking off all those nice
fragrant little time flowers
you can hear it crackling in the
background
these are cannellini beans
they're waxy
very soft
and so delicious but very dense
but for stuffing they're so robust
nothing breaks down
drain them off
in
they're going to take on all that juice
as well from this freezer i'm going to
season them now because they're very
dense so it needs some help
i mean that looks like it's
a dish on its own
good enough to eat now
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
tomatoes half dried
in
that sweetens up
the stuffing
beautiful
the stuffing's ready look at the color
everything
looks spanish it looks delicious
now
stuffing the chicken i like taking off
these little knuckles
as the chicken cooks the skin stretches
over the bone you can get a really nice
drum and take off those little wingtips
as well
salt pepper
so important
now
you're stuffing
i'm gonna go right inside the chicken
push it down this really helps to cook
the bird evenly because you're pushing
out all the empty spaces in the carcass
and take a nice large lemon
push the lemon in
pick up the person's nose pull the skin
over olive oil on top
salt
and pepper
a teaspoon of paprika
sprinkle it on and then get your hands
and sort of rub that in
and see what the paprika is doing to the
chicken put this like sweet spicy
marinade
it's not even roasted yet but it looks
delicious
400ml of white wine same quantity of
water that helps the chicken to steam
chicken in
be generous with the time sprigs
[Music]
make sure the fall is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chicken
steams in the oven keeping it moist and
juicy
into the oven
[Music]
cook for one hour at 180 degrees with a
foil on nice
take it out and remove the full lid then
give it another 30 minutes to crisp up
that skin
look at that
it's so important to make sure you take
that tinfoil off with half an hour to go
beautiful
pierce that open
squeeze it in
that delicious gravy mix that into the
tray
and sieve that
that's really nice fragrant lemony
spiced roasting juices to finish
before we cut up the chicken take out
amazing stuffing
[Music]
incredible i'd have that with chicken
over potatoes any day
and then just get your
chicken roasting juices
now
to cut the chicken up
hold the drum
and slice straight through
and there's a wonderful
drum and the thigh through the wishbone
off
slice with the point at an angle so you
can see the texture
of that amazing roast chicken
just take my cooking juices just want to
give a nice sort of lemony
flavor
over my chicken and there you go
a delicious
very charming stuffed
roast chicken
[Music]